like soon as the shooting is taking
place we move in
we move in and we strive to identify the
guys that are involved identify the
reasons and the circumstances around
them and then try to bring logic into it
and try to separate people we even do
what we call aggressive shadowing if we
see a guy that's so emotionally involved
one of us would connect ourselves to him
and call him every five minutes try to
get around him every two three minutes
to try to get him in on another path
another way of thinking
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bring to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about violence on
the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as we possibly can
to build a community center on this much
needed block called o block it's called
o block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs picked up the o in his
name and started calling it o block we
decided we like the o but we're going to
change it to opportunity block so we are
so thankful to fox for giving us the
opportunity today to bring to you every
day rooftop revelations where i share
with you my viewpoints thoughts and
opinions on matters as it relates to
chicago and across america today
i have a very special guest
to talk about just the issue
of violence in chicago and what we're
doing in this community to solve it and
how we believe that this model can be a
model for across america so i want to
welcome to rooftop revelations mr james
hi smith
hi smith how you doing man
so listen let's jump right in
a lot of people may be asking
what is a violence prevention team
you know and why do we need why does
project hood or why does the city of
chicago need a violence prevention team
so can you explain
to our our listeners what is a violence
prevention team
my volunteer
prevention team is a team that is
working directly on the street boots on
the ground working with individuals is
most likely to shoot or be shot
our main objective is we work by the
public health
approach where we recognize violence and
stuff somewhat like a disease
and what we try to do is
interrupt the transmission
between uh
violence being being spreaded from one
individual or from one group to another
in the process of doing that we we have
a lot of different approaches
uh however the most important thing is
division of project hood
which is to change the whole narrative
about violence
we recognize that most things are done
by choice
and everyone in our community has a
choice however they don't have that many
options
so that limited the choice
what we're trying to do at project hood
is is broadening the rise in our
broadened scope in regards to how many
options we can give people that they can
change to the norm about which supports
violence right so i know you serve as
the director uh for the project hood
violence prevention team
um but tell us a little bit about
your team like what's the makeup of it
well
i'm so grateful and it's important that
you uh
ask that question faster because what it
is
is that
my particular team
let me rephrase that the team of project
hood has put together
is a team that is
this is is rooted
in history and birth
in the woodlawn community
they have a background in the organ
and the most important part about our
team
is that they got they are connected by
blood
i have i have five
individuals that are members of this
team an integral part of this team who
have lost
their children
to violence
the gun violence in particular
i have one individual
who has lost
she's she's the most powerful one of my
most powerful outreach workers she lost
two sons to gun violence two
not one
two
i have another
who have lost
his daughter
who was less than six months old in his
arms and was shot in his arms
yes we are we're connected by blood it's
they are they are
so sincere about what they work because
they got blood in the game
and that makes you more powerful and
more personal
so hi smith so let me ask you this so
those individuals uh who work on the
team
how do they stop the violence how do
they intervene because i heard you
mentioned earlier that part of the the
uh
the team's mission is to intervene in
these issues but for a person who's
listening they're thinking okay how do
they how do they intervene
with somebody stop to help stop them
from being shot at retaliation how how
does that work well
pastor is not really that complicated
when you got individuals who grew up in
the area know the individuals who are
doing this and get into the cracks and
crevices of the community where they
get wind of situations and circumstances
prior to them happening i'm not talking
about sporadic shootings or sporadic
killings that that is that it happens
spur the moment i'm talking about things
that build up from historical
uh conflicts among groups different
things of that nature where individuals
can come into it and uh
put an input in to try to separate them
give them more logic give them more
options give them more ideas about how
we should not do that right you know but
then in retaliation
uh we have a a
mechanism in place where we try to get
our individuals as soon as the shooting
is uh uh was committed as soon as the
shooting is taking place we move in
we move in and we try to identify the
guys that are involved identify the
reasons and the circumstances around
them and then try to bring logic into it
and try to separate people we even do
what we call aggressive shadowing and we
see a guy that's so emotionally involved
one of us will connect ourselves to him
and call him every five minutes try to
get around him every two three minutes
to try to get hit him in one another's
path another way of thinking all right
especially when it's retaliation right
one of the things i want to talk about
before we end is i know you're working
on something very special and um
you're working on a truce a gang truce
can you explain
what a gang truce is
and why we need it in this community and
just tell us about what's going on well
years ago the gang cruisers when two
organizations with groups would decide
not to shoot no more try to get a
peaceful thing at this point with so
many shootings and so many violence has
taken place people lost it long but they
lost their loved ones and different
things we're pushing towards what you
call a
non-aggressive aggression
uh agreement in other words what that
means is that we try to get these guys
to say hey look
you stay on your side they still on this
side you know what i mean don't slide
over there and don't think flat over
here if we get them to agree to that
just that little simple thing right
there then we have an opportunity to
move in to broaden
[Music]
working with each one of these people
put them in workshops we got so many
non-violent workshops that we
put together for these jobs to sit down
and talk this stuff out
talk about why are you doing that do it
make actually make sense so the the
groups y'all been getting together how
you do you feel like that's working
because i know it's a lot of different
guys from a lot of different cliques
that y'all got trying to come together
how is that working right now
we're taking baby steps but right now we
had a lure in uh shootings uh we're
working with them bringing them together
we haven't brought them together face to
face but we're working with them by
working with each and every one of them
in their own groups and
we build it and i've been not and i'm
very very uh optimistic that this is
that this is going to take place and
we're going to have a more calm and more
tranquil some of this stuff and that's
the goal have a and tranquil summer
because
the truth of the matter is in chicago
has been a lot of violence a lot of
shootings and so we need violence
prevention teams we need people with
boots on the ground so thank you for the
work you do thank you for the leadership
you provide thank you for uh
consistently uh caring about what goes
on in the wood line and training all
these brothers and sisters to do the
work i appreciate it
also i appreciate you giving me the
opportunity absolutely
listen it's been a blessing you're
always say god bless you god bless
america and thank you for tuning in to
rooftop revelations and until tomorrow
peace
you